what are you going to do when you leave
school are you going to do a degree and
if you do a degree how useful is that
going to be and what job you get you
know there's this pressure to keep going
and that's all wrapped up with a focus
on you have to be a success particularly
as a bloke not what is it you actually
want to do with your life
matt rudd welcome to the show thanks for
having me chris it's good to be here
does life get any easier as you get
older in your experience
no
thanks for having me it's been great to
be here speak to you next time
life doesn't get easier
i think
well
people get happier when they're a lot
older that's the thing you know about
the happiness curve
so
the low point is in your 40s and then
where you hit rock bottom
and then things start to pick up again
when you don't care so much about stuff
so i'm looking forward to my 60th
birthday because that's peak happiness
why do you think that is why is this a
u-shaped curve
well that's that's the whole that's the
whole book isn't it it's why why is it
you know the points where you've
achieved
everything if you're lucky that you know
society expects to you to do
why is it
that just at that point
you're you're
extremely unhappy or not extremely
unhappy quite unhappy i mean i
it's there's a lot of reasons
i think
i think the main one in my own
experience was
you know i'd done all these five-year
plans i'd
been you know done the exams done gone
to university gone up the you know
uh job ladder climbed the career ladder
and
got married had kids all the traditional
stuff and then i kind of popped my head
up at the age of 43
and
just didn't know what to do next and i
was waking up in the middle of the night
i was catastrophizing
i couldn't sleep and it just got worse
and worse and and what was interesting i
think
you have your own experience it sounds
like you know you had quite a few
extreme things going on but for me it
was it wasn't a crisis it was more like
doldrums midlife doldrums which i think
is much more common if you have a full
bone blown crisis
you're forced to kind of confront what's
going on and
and and
try to change things but for most of us
it's a kind of struggling on scenario
that's something that i think about an
awful lot that if you hit rock bottom
there's only one place to go from there
it's one of the reasons why when you
watch a movie and the hero
falls from grace and then he's drinking
and in the gutter and stuff there's a
certain amount of romanticism around
that because you know that there's only
one direction for him to go from there
and the same as anybody that's gone to
the gym if you try and
three-quarter squat and then go up from
there it's pretty difficult but if you
bounce out of the bottom it's actually
relatively easy and i think that you
have this in life too that people can
become sedated by comfort that life's
not that good but it's not that bad
either you don't have the activation
energy to actually kick you out of the
bottom of whatever you're dealing with
and yeah that's sort of uh
sedation by
comfort complacency like not giving up
the average for the good are they good
for the great i think that's where a lot
of people find themselves
and also fear i think
for men in particular
it's
it's fear when i when i first started
feeling
you know like i was struggling
i couldn't really access
well-being books i just found it all too
much so i started talking to
other men
and a lot of them you know i i talked to
them because to me they look like they
had it all together so i'd find out how
they were managing
and
after you know two pints into the
conversation it was clear that they were
also struggling with what was going
around their heads
but
an alarming amount of them said i just
don't want to talk about this because
i can't start thinking about me and life
because i've got all these plates
spinning this is a real midlife thing as
well you've got dependence you've got
you're hanging on to a lot of different
things and if you start
what they saw as being indulgent
and
thinking about life
the whole plate spinning thing you know
the house of cards could fall down so
there's fear i think is a
fear just it's easier to keep your head
down
plow on
german soldier syndrome is how one
psychologist described it to me
yeah you've got this quote where you say
if i start worrying about the meaning of
life i'll go mad i just have to keep
going and that's another part of
sedation right that people find they
sedate themselves with busyness too
yes and it is
better to keep struggling on and keep
what you've got than what
i saw and what they see as risking
losing it all
yeah it's um
the indulgent thing is something that i
find so interesting
i had throughout my 20s i had
bouts of
not super acute but depression i
wouldn't get out of bed for a few days
at the time i was running these
nightclubs i was going to bed i mean my
sleeping pattern was
disgusting and all over the place and i
wasn't eating well and i was partying a
good bit and so on and so forth and i
would just have these periods after i
worked for a very long time where i
couldn't get out of bed and i was like
what's happening is this because i'm
weak is this because i'm deficient in
some way and that was the you know the
fact that you're in bed and stuff you
don't feel very good with whatever the
emotions are that are going around
but the worst thing is the second order
self-referential shame and guilt around
the fact that you know
okay so ostensibly what is actually
wrong and you go well nothing it's just
the weight of [ __ ] existence and you
think to yourself
how
bourgeois
and indulgent and wanky is this to say
that in a life where i don't technically
have anything going wrong if someone was
to come up to me and say dude i went i
remember i went to my gp and this was a
while ago this was probably 10
10 or 12 years ago and i think and hope
that mental health
discussions have probably improved in
the nhs since then i went to go and
speak to my gp and i said um i don't
feel very good i'm having these sort of
bouts of feeling a bit low and stuff
he said oh well what's wrong
and i kind of said well i don't have any
financial problems i haven't recently
split up i'm not in grief i'm not
there's no like nothing is hanging over
me other than the sheer weight of
existence itself
uh and she gave me like a single page
printout and sort of ushered me on my
way
i thought well
that didn't really help and it also put
a bit of a
not a bad taste in my mouth but it made
me hesitant about seeking help again in
future too
yeah and as we know
men are very reluctant to ask and seek
help either from friends
or from medical professionals so the
fact that you'd actually overcome that
first hurdle puts you already in a big
minority
there's there's things going on here
there's the
it is it men do see it as indulgent
to try and seek help for themselves
because
we're conditioned from a very young age
to be strong
and to be successful and and not to fail
and you know there are better much more
expert people who've been very profound
about all this but the
the toxic effect of having to be strong
and therefore bracket silent
is is a real problem
but yeah so fear and
worrying about showing weakness
are the twin pillars that
mean you end up you rock up in your 40s
in in the place i did
or you just plow on until you you know
you get the gold watch which is what
which is what the vast majority of
people
i've interviewed for this book were
doing that was their attitude keep going
not much longer to go which is a really
depressing
concept actually
yeah that you have the innocent playful
beauty of childhood then just this huge
swath of hiding from your existential
anomie until you hit 60 at which time
everything can be okay again yeah
and
the thing is i don't i don't think
you have to make any
radical changes that's the interesting
thing what you've got to do
is something i've missed the opportunity
i'll do it from now on but it's just
pausing
stopping and
thinking
you know what is what am i doing here
is this the thing am i too focused on
that where's the happiness in this and
it's trying to just stop the
the external pressure that you must
succeed
as well as your own inner monologue
telling you keep going don't break
uh you've got to try and put these
pauses in and i don't think i
i don't think i really stopped and
thought until i was in my mid-40s i had
such a
clear
set of hurdles to get over at each stage
of life
which we all have
and
you just don't feel that that you can
can stop and think what am i doing here
even if you carry on doing the same
thing
there was one guy i spoke to who
he he just graduated and he wanted to go
he wanted to be an author
and then
he was i met him and i was just talking
giving trying to give him some careers
advice
and he was in a real panic and he was
considering doing he just graduated he
was going to do a masters so another
year in university and he described it
as a panic masters
he wasn't doing it because he wanted to
you know grow his brain
or
because he enjoyed education he was
doing it because he was so concerned
that on his cv there would be this sort
of gap
so he was going to just do it sit
through another year of lectures just so
there wasn't a gap and so i i just said
this is this is ridiculous
how how long have you been
trying to be an author how long have you
been sending off your cvs five weeks
so that i mean that's it it is so much
worse now for the next generation
although you know the language is better
and
men are more open hopefully than they
were
20 years ago and certainly more than
they were
when my father was a kid or a hundred
years ago we have the victorians to
thank for our very slow recovery from
all of that
the pressure is just greater now
what's your thoughts on the conversation
around mental health generally at the
moment and then specifically for men
because i
i've really really struggled
to resonate with a lot of the campaigns
around it's okay to talk and ask twice
and stuff like that
i don't know whether
the problem is bigger than that whether
a little social change campaign and a
cool hashtag
is uh insufficient to fix it um i
understand that it's coming from a good
place of people trying to open up a
conversation about mental health it's
never really resonated with me that much
and i'm someone that's you know suffered
with mental health problems before in
the past incredibly compassionate and
passionate about
trying to help it in future what do you
think about the the current conversation
it has become ah this is tricky but it
has become quite trendy and for instance
at my workplace i get an email every
week asking me to fill out a well-being
survey
which is quite annoying actually i'd
rather
you know is it damaging your well-being
to fill out the well-being survey
it's damaging i hate filling out surveys
anyway every time i buy something i have
to fill out a survey
so
that's that's not great
all i all i can say and i think the more
you hear something it's good to talk men
should open up more you kind of become
blind that you kind of shut shut down as
i said before
i
you know five years ago i just wouldn't
have listened to a podcast like this and
i wouldn't have bought a self-help book
because i just found it too much i was
not ready to be at step one
so
and that's typical from for a lot of men
in particular
the talking actually and now i'm going
to say it is good to talk that was the
thing that for me made a change and it
wasn't just
you know
going to the pub with your mates and
having a chat you have to actually kind
of
force them
to be
serious you know say look this is how
i'm feeling which is
really tricky to get through but then
once you start talking
you know the idea that men can't talk
are silent
it's nonsense like i spoke to so many
men over the last three or four years
first friends and then you know
wider
and once they start it it's it's really
profound and that was for me the thing
that that made the biggest change that
enabled me to then start accessing other
things the idea that i it's not just me
i'm not the
i'm not the weird guy waking up at three
o'clock in the morning and worrying
about
if i get mortgage insurance will i not
be able to afford the mortgage like
stupid things like that so
yeah
talking is good but it's also you've got
to overcome this there's embarrassment
shame all of that that goes with it
so it's a it's a three pint problem
all right is that the optimal
uh inebriation level maximum yeah
maximum integration level
i've tried both those things i've tried
not drinking and i've tried drinking far
too much and that doesn't particularly
work either
is it really true
just to say some way completely that you
haven't seen with nelloni
yes it's true and i feel like i'm being
gaslit into an alternate universe i've
never heard of it
i don't know what it is mary harrington
looked like i'd killed her brand new
puppy when i said that i hadn't done it
and then i tried to reach out to my own
audience on twitter in a desperate
attempt to get some sort of backup and
was further lambasted by them so
yeah i i don't know what it is
this is the other contributing factor to
the midlife doldrums as you start
referencing incredibly
famous
cultural moments and people haven't
heard of it because they were two when
it when it came out did you see there
was this meme that went hyper viral
after the super bowl
and
uh
it was a tweet and someone said
i realized whilst watching the super
bowl and thought oh
really good that they're bringing out
all of these current artists and not
those old throwbacks for people that are
way older when they then realized that
dr dre and 50 cent and eminem and mary j
blige came out in like
20 years ago
and realized at that moment that you are
now
the boomers that previously you would
have been
insulting so here's a question when do
you become old or how do you know when
you're starting to get old
i wrote about this in my column this
week actually and i've got a fairly
graphic answer
do you want the graphic answer
absolutely sorry a very wise friend of
mine once told me that uh in order
in order to
to deal with the post p dribble
you have to you've got to trick it chris
okay so if you finish you shake three
times no more
definitely no more
you and then you put it away and as
you're putting it away you mustn't your
brain mustn't connect
to know what's coming next but then you
whip it out again
and it comes out and when you know
you're old
is when you have to do that twice
and i wrote that in the paper at the
weekend and a friend got in touch and
said wait till you're 60 then it's four
times
that was not a serious answer to your
question and i apologize but
what what is what is uh
happy a happy thought is that when i
talk about getting old
in the newspaper i get lots of uh
readers getting in touch saying i'm 78
and i've never felt younger
so i do think what i think actually is
the trick is to navigate through the
midlife
and and get out the other side intact
without feeling like you've just been
working
yeah i this is something that i want to
have a conversation about more so i'm 34
right i was 34 last week and um
it feels very strange because at 34
you're you're definitely out of young
adulthood i think
you're definitely out of the stage where
all of the rules that you used to have
in your 20s could work people are
expecting you to kind of have your [ __ ]
together at least a little bit more
and you are for the first time ever
each year that comes by
you're not necessarily
fitter
in terms of what you can do athletically
or in terms of the way that you look
than you were the year before whereas
throughout your 20s each year you're
getting whatever you're in the gym more
muscle mass you're getting stronger
you're
more confident you're whatever it might
be
and then there is a point where you
reach uh like attractiveness apogee even
as a man
and then you start to say oh
hold on a second where's this progress
coming from it's actually taken me
longer to recover from workouts you know
it's taken me forever to recover from a
hangover for quite a while now but
everything starts to get a little bit
and there is a sense of like at the top
of a roller coaster ride that
weightlessness and you're going whoa
hang on a second and that's something
that you know you
for the people that are below the age of
30 you'd start to realize you're
chronically aware of your own mortality
when you start to
understand that you're not as
unbreakable as you thought that you were
before i snapped an achilles a couple of
years ago playing cricket like the most
british way to rupture an achilles ever
uh
and yeah you know
i think that the conversation around
aging for men as well is a different one
because everybody is so
hyper aware of the
implications of aging for women
and the fact that women are very often
judged by their beauty and the way that
they look and aging kind of runs against
that uh whereas for men to say you know
about aging it's you're supposed to
become the hairy ass bloke right with a
pint in his hand that's kind of one of
the the tropes
yeah but
i mean it is easier for men it is easier
because because it's okay to go gray or
bald or
whatever happens
i think i think the the change
is
to go back to what i was saying earlier
it's when you don't have an immediately
obvious roadmap anymore so
for me with having three kids
once
it's when they're when they're very
young you've got a load of mechanical
processes to get through just to get out
of the door in the morning
and then
it's the same with you with with your
job you know you've got you're at the
bottom of the ladder
the only way is up and then you reach
this point where
you know the kids are becoming more
self-sufficient and they're leaving home
and you get to the point in the career
where
you kind of don't want to go up anymore
because to go up is more pressure and
more time and all the rest of it
but in our culture people who don't want
to move up
are viewed with with suspicion
and it can be seen as a as a negative
that you want to do the same thing or
you don't want to take on more
responsibilities
and as so there's this kind of just
the
certainty of youth
falls away into this kind of less
certain
less obvious way of moving forward and
that's that isn't old that's not old
but it's the sort of
you can see you can see backwards to
where you've come from
and then there's this kind of blur that
feels scary you know your 40s and your
50s and then you know then you are old
you said that the system largely set up
by men for men isn't working for the
vast majority of men and i think that
this is where
attention
lies that you have this
you know for a very long time
patriarchal society that was
created to
and
largely facilitated in an attempt to try
and encourage men and assist them and
you know we've recently only just about
reached gender equality with stuff um so
for men to start complaining about the
fact that there's a problem with this
society does feel indulgent uh
not only on the individual level but on
a system-wide level too and it's quite
easy i think to
wave away the concerns of men because
you say well look look at all of the
things that you've had for all of this
time
you know
is this just you complaining about the
fact that finally you haven't got the
situation the way that you want you go
well no it's
it's a fact that neither men nor women
are fantastically happy all the time at
the moment
exactly and that and that is that's the
point
of the book because
if it's not working for us then it's not
working for anyone is is the point you
know and
if you look at the figures it there is a
real spike in in depression and suicide
with men in the particularly in the 45
to 49 bracket
so it's trying to it's trying to work
out how on earth we got there and i i've
had written a lot of this and done a lot
of the research for this
before the pandemic and i was kind of
doing the revises
as we were moving into lockdown and
suddenly a lot of the things that i was
saying might be better that men do want
to have a work-life balance they do want
to be involved with their families all
of those things suddenly that was thrust
upon us that you know the pandemic was
the
magic answer to everything i was
whinging about in the book in a in a
fairly extreme and
dark way
but you know now we're at a point where
we're coming out of it hopefully and
very quickly
and everyone's saying i can't wait for
it to get back to how it was
but we need to be careful not to
you know we we with it was such a
dramatic shift
and
everyone i'd been speaking to was
suddenly saying oh it's great i can do
the well not the school run but i can
get the kids ready in the morning i can
be there in meetings on zoom
you could see you know kids running in
and out of the background it was like
yeah we do actually have a family we you
know we are men but this is our family
and it's all things that women have been
juggling with for a lot longer
and it's been really interesting
to see all of that i just
think it's very important that
particularly for the next generation who
are obviously more eager than us old
farts to get back to how life was
that they hang on to this kind of weird
hybrid
part working from home part working from
office
thing as we as we return to whatever
normally is if it goes back to how it
was that's going to be a disaster
how would you what's your post-mortem of
the working from home with a family
situation like you say do you do you
feel like you should be careful what you
wish for
uh i don't know what it was like for you
before we started this i had to go and
shout at everyone to get off the wi-fi
that's so so it's i'm i'm
saying how wonderful it all is but
there's there's pressures i
i think we all got quite tired of it and
it's nice to it's nice to be going back
um
but i certainly feel that i know my kids
better at the end of all this than i did
before and that's that is a i keep
mentioning kids and work but that's the
real
part of all of this all of the reasons
why
this system that has supposedly was set
up for men and is supposedly for men
hasn't been working it's that kind of
patriarchal you're the provider
and
the woman's looking after the kids and
what's happened is
women have
and it's a great thing obviously
being moved into the workplace so
but there hasn't
men haven't made any real effort to
move the other the other direction oh so
women's
women have been facilitated at moving
into the workplace but men haven't been
facilitated at moving back into the
household
yeah and you see it you see it in
particular with
uh
with parental leave so i got a week off
for each kid you know i go
have to watch my wife nearly dying
72-hour labor it was worse for her i
know that but watching it
is is also bad
and then you know get finally get home
try and clear the you know the detritus
of of the remnants of the the failed
home birth up to get it ready and then
i'm back at home a day back at work a
day a day later and my colleagues go
everything right and i say yes
and that's how you did it
so but now just you know 15 years on
that's already beginning to change
you
i spent some time with an insurance
company that had decided to give both to
give
shared parental leave regardless of
gender
you get six months off and i had to go
and talk to these really annoying people
who were all just so happy
and balanced they'd returned to work all
excited about being back at work they'd
established a bond with their sons and
daughters you know it was it was great
and i would be very very surprised if in
10 15 years that's just not a universal
policy because it also helps the
employer productivity had gone up
i don't know if it was because the dads
were just so relieved to be getting back
to the office or whether it's because
they'd had a little break from the rat
race you know they'd they got off the
hamster wheel to to name another rodent
and uh
you know they
it's it's all just trying to disrupt
that idea that you're just slogging away
from
age 18 to age 65
or in your case
68
it's going to be interesting to see
what happens with people who are
increasingly in the gig economy
you know we've had this recent opening
of working from home of people being
able to determine their own working
hours freelance fiverr
all of these sorts of organizations or
people that are just starting businesses
you know you can have
this show is a business on its own you
know it doesn't have a premises
who am i going to get leave off who's
going to pay me the leave no one so very
much
with an increase in people perhaps
starting small and medium-sized
companies or just commercializing
themselves and their own talents um
that's going to be another challenge
that more and more men and women are
going to have to face you know when it
comes to no one's paying you maternity
or paternity leave in that way
yeah and there's an illusion there that
you have more freedom
you're working for yourself almost and
you can
pick and choose your hours and etc etc
but workers rights go out with that
it's difficult i mean starting your own
business is a different thing isn't it
which which you know much more about
than i do
but
that has all the same associated
pressures and it's the it's the broader
theme of
you know pursuing stuff and pursuing
success and how important is that
and i would argue
that it is it's such an obvious thing to
say but it's far less important than
than
happiness and balance
and this is where you you're in danger
of ending up sounding like a
full-on monkish self-help guru who
that's really really hard when you've
got responsibilities and overheads and
all the rest of it
yeah talking about
letting go
of
chasing
commercial monetary status full
possessional success is i i keep on
having this a lot at the moment
and i think that it's because there
really isn't
much of a
aspirational especially for men an
aspirational
role model or archetype that they can
follow that isn't the monk that just
recounts all worldly possessions and
decides to go live upon a hill it's not
very cool to say
do you know what it is i i'm i'm good
materially i'm i'm fine with this
position with earning this many thousand
pounds per year without just ruthlessly
chasing whatever the next you said
earlier on more promotion more stress
more responsibility
there isn't i'm not seeing many
conversations between people especially
men saying
i'm good where i am i i've reached the
um position that i need to be at i've
reached the monetary wealth i need to be
at and now i can actually
use the time in that i've invested so
far to pivot me to a lifestyle that i
want to have a much more sort of
holistic view
of progression and self-improvement and
growth and earning
it is difficult and i'm and i'm saying
all of this but i i still have you know
i'm still envy other people and i still
look at or someone's got that and
it
it's really built into things from the
very beginning you know there's there's
so much keeping up with the joneses
and
i don't i don't know what the answer is
i know the answer isn't people like me
saying
don't have so much stuff
but
it is it is very you know we are in a
materialistic culture
and
i am old enough to now realize that
having the latest gadgets and the latest
you know a telly and a flash car is
definitely not not the answer
how you how you convey that because i
think everyone knows it but it's kind of
there's a beneath the surface
uh
envy and a need to keep up with other
people that is it's really difficult and
it it has it must all be
built into
early life
and being encouraged to succeed again it
all goes back you know how do you show
that you are successful
if you don't have all the stuff
and that's that's a difficulty you know
when you were describing
not you know
not accumulating stuff that would be
classed as quite sort of beta male oh
right he doesn't
he doesn't need things so great but i
want to show
i want to show
my to you know i want to get external
validation
and in order to do that
i need stuff and by stuff it can also
include you know
success at work
job titles women achievements followers
online
i can't remember women because i've been
married for 16 years but that's
definitely
instagram followers
and i you know when i was getting ready
for this i did have a little peek at how
many instagram followers you got and
you've got loads
like
loads and i thought i've got
not that many at all you see it's all
the time it's it's not as simple as
my neighbor's got a nicer car than me
here's a couple of insights around
especially the alpha beat and sigma this
sigma now i'm not sure if you're
familiar with that but there's a sigma
mail to it that's basically anyone who
tries to be keanu reeves
and one of the insights around this is
most of the guys that i know that are um
unreservedly chasing accomplishments and
women
really should be looked on with pity i
think dude like
this is you filling a hole inside of
yourself the sense of insufficiency that
you have
the only way that you can satisfy that
is by continually chasing
women and achievements and money and
external validation and success and all
of this stuff and it's that quote what
is it um
this person's so poor that all they have
are money
to keep them going
uh and another side of this is that
if you have if you're the sort of person
especially a guy who is
not materialistically driven
i think that that should be seen as a
competitive advantage
you can be happy at 100 grand a year
you can have the same level of happiness
at 100 grand a year versus your friend
who grew up maybe in a more
materialistic household maybe people
showed their love and affection by
buying each other gifts maybe there was
a keeping up with the joneses
environment or whatever
and that person's got to get to a
million now maybe it's not ten times
harder to get from a hundred thousand to
a million as it was to get from not to a
hundred thousand but still you can say
look
i'm i'm good this is where i want to be
at and really genuinely leaning into
that and
understanding having a low materialism
set point or a lower comparatively
materialism set point
is
a i mean how many people pity the guy
that's in a in a marriage and yet still
feels the need to
message girls on instagram or keep on
you know when he's away on a stag do on
a weekend with the boys because he knows
his missus isn't going to find out
decides to sleep around you pity that
guy because you think you haven't been
able to find a sense of security and
solace in your relationship to the point
where you're having to go and do things
that
your integrity and your virtue aren't
aligned with and if they are aligned
with it then your integrity and your
virtue are [ __ ] so yeah i think that
there's there are some solid places for
men to stand with this
again like i'm saying this to myself as
much as i'm saying it to anybody else
right i'm
not the role model i simply kind of have
an idea of the path but i think
increasingly as you see these archetypes
of guys
relinquishing that materialistic push
relinquishing those external measures of
success as being them
internal measures of self-worth the more
that we can try and do that and i do
think it's happening more i think the
better it's going to be for everybody
including the wives of the men that this
is happening to
yeah and they they've been
loads of studies over the years where
they've tried to put a price on
happiness
and you know so in the states the you
know the
you need to earn
x
thousand dollars in order to be happy
and then it diminishes very very quickly
after that
but i don't i don't think
it it's not really there isn't a price
obviously there isn't a price because
there's so many different circumstances
uh i mean for me i was i was quite
pleased with myself when i was in my 20s
because i deliberately picked
journalism as opposed to you know
friends who were going on to become
lawyers or
management consultants i still don't
know what a management management
consultant does but they were all
earning a lot of money when they were
young
and i felt i felt superior to them i
mean it's just ridiculous it's it's more
kind of
weird comparing yourself to other people
because i was choosing what was then a
noble art of journalism and i
you know how how great is that
um i felt good about it but then the
reality is
i was doing it so i could see my name in
a paper
or a tiny little tractor magazine or
whatever it was back then and you just
so it's still doing things for the wrong
for the wrong reasons
and i think so and now when you talk to
younger people
they're going through all of those
different emotions and thoughts but with
this
huge pressure to to to
get moving and get going and that's much
higher than it used to be you know you
didn't used to have
careers advice fairs starting from the
age of 14 and you didn't used to have
such vocational you know it's all about
what are you going to do when you leave
school what are you going to do
are you going to do a degree and if you
do a degree how useful is that going to
be and what job you get you know there's
this pressure to
keep going
moving forward
and that's all wrapped up with a focus
on you have to be a success
particularly as a bloke
not
what is it you actually want to do what
what is it you want to do with your life
so
sorry go on just how do you think school
plays a role here at defining the
framework that men step into the boys
that will later become men
so so much
in in the way that the classroom is and
also in the way that peer groups
work so you've got on the one hand
this
you're it's all about
grades
whenever you hear the government talking
about
education it's all about
getting getting good grades there's
nothing there's no kind of holistic
approach to how to be a man
there's i mean the
sex education when i was at school was
one you know one biology lesson where
the
embarrassed teacher showed you a
cross-section on the overhead projector
of a sliced penis
you won't know what an overhead
projector is will you now i'm going to
feel old again no this is this is my
world as well right fine
and now it's kind of a bit more involved
but in in sweden they have sex week a
whole week where everyone's discussing
not just sex but relationships and what
it means to be a man and what it means
to be a woman
and
the whole of kind of
relationships well-being and how to how
to
live a life is built not just into that
week but in throughout the curriculum in
all the different classes so it's just
completely natural for people to be anal
for swedish kids to be analyzing what it
what you know what they expect out of
their life
when they get older not just out of
their job
and so you know that's it's it's really
fundamental and then you've got the you
know the
the peer group where it's you know it's
pack mentality they're recovering from
the having to sit still and be polite
and
etc in the classroom so outside of that
it's it's kind of lord of the flies
an
interesting uh undercurrent to
the fact that grades are so important i
don't know whether this is the same in
america but certainly in the uk
it it is a zero-sum game
when it comes to the way that
distributions for grades are done
because they can't have it's always the
same proportion of a stars a's b's c's
d's etc right and that means that if the
entire
um school
improves nobody actually moves if
everyone improves at the same rate so it
embedded that competitive nature is
literally embedded into the structure of
how school works at least in the uk
it was which is crazy when you think
about it because we're all talking about
how do you improve
education and if they're fixated on
grades
having that you know finite number of a
stars
how can you possibly improve it doesn't
it's not mathematically possible and the
other thing
that happens
in in the states i think and
particularly in the uk is start them
earlier we need to get them going you
know let's have a sure start so get them
into school at four but
get them thinking about school before
that
in germany they don't really start
formal education you know sitting at a
desk which is not an ideal place for
for any kid but in particular a boy
until they're eight
and they have better results are coming
out the other end
so they have a chance to be a kid
and to climb trees is what i'm
romantically thinking but it's probably
just sitting on an ipad in hamburg
whereas our kids from the age of four
are sat at a desk being told to behave
and if they behave they get a gold star
so that's external validation and off we
go
and you could
everything you've ever discussed on on
all your episodes of your podcast if we
got the first
four years right
that a huge amount of the problems that
come up in later life would be dealt
with do you think that's right
yeah absolutely everything is i mean
it's that's the sort of
the most developmental stage of the
brain it's when things are being
hardwired of you know what to expect am
i is is this a loving
world or is it a tough world
and you know you
flinging them off into school
at such a young age
it's it hard wires that
life is hard and we you need to succeed
which is really not a great thing to be
teaching kids
you know toddlers
what do you thought about the
relationship between men and technology
well you know my thoughts because we
started this conversation with you
telling me i needed to restart my
computer
and that led to a 20 minute running
around the house trying to find another
computer that hadn't automatically
updated itself so thank you for that
chris my blood pressure's almost gone
down
i mean it's really obvious that
technology
is in some ways great we're talking to
each other now remotely i'm able to you
know have fed the kids before we started
this that wouldn't be possible without
the joy of whatever thing we're on
but as everyone has been saying for a
long time it's it's all pervasive
you can't
can't get away from it
it's again it's done all sorts of damage
to
to childhood and it has a huge impact on
relationships in
teens and young adults i mean it's just
depressing it's depressing talking to 20
somethings about dating
because it's
it's all blind dates i'm gonna sound
like a really cantankerous old man but i
and i'm also talking to the wrong guy
here as well blind dates anyway we
didn't have blind dates 20 years ago but
now it's all you know it's all done on
the on the apps
so
i would love
and as soon as i do get to the gold
watch i will i will have
as little technology as possible and i
reached that conclusion
when
we got a smart
smart thermometer
no a smart thermostat
do you have one of these no but i've
been in houses like a nest type thing
that thing i didn't know we were gonna
name it because i'm going to be rude
about it but
before we had a dial and a switch so if
you wanted it on a certain time you did
the thing
and now because technology makes life so
much more efficient
we have
the nest
with an app
that you have to set and it has a life
of its own because it it has decided and
i agree with with the thought but it has
decided it needs to be eco
it's impossible to turn it off eco
so it comes on for 20 minutes in the
middle of the night and i should say
that you know three years after my sort
of mid-life doldrums i was starting to
sleep through the night
but now the thermostat puts the heating
on so i'm up and we can't anyway i it
met a hammer
and that would be mine
[Laughter]
that will be my that will be what i do
as soon as i don't have to be on
technology i won't
so you're i'm not being a cantankerous
old man but also being a luddite at the
same time we've managed to blend these
two worlds together have we
yeah well what do you i mean what do you
do because your your whole life your
whole work is is you know
technology is critical to it but how do
you how do you do
everyone always says don't take your
phone to your bedroom don't check your
phone after a certain that can are you
able
are you able to have limits do you have
balance or do you just have
your iphone
shouting at you because you've been on
the phone for 36 hours this week
permanently attached to my right hand
well
it feels like fighting a losing battle
right i'm very i have been ever since i
started this podcast four years ago very
skeptical around technology in our
relationship with it tristan harris from
the center for humane technology was a
huge influence on me and has been for
half a decade now um so yeah it's
sleeping with the phone outside of the
bedroom
uh doing intermittent fasting for your
phone so you don't use it before a
certain time and you don't use it after
a certain time but it does feel an awful
lot like we are
putting band-aids over bullet wounds
here that the fundamental technology the
limbic hijack the addictive nature of it
the fact that it gives us social
approval the fact that it is necessary
and there's a kernel of truth in the
fact that you need to use it because
you've got to get the uber or you need
to navigate where you're going on google
maps or what about if somebody needs to
message you or whatever um
i wonder whether we're going to be
looked back on by future generations
in the same way as i know people that
held slaves or something just like this
primitive
ridiculous situation that we managed to
put humanity into that you couldn't bear
thinking was ever going to happen again
in future i wonder whether i i think in
future we're probably going to look back
on factory farming with a fair bit of
disgust and say like this is how on
earth were we we were so uncivilized and
so sort of
terrible but i wonder whether we're
going to look back on this period and
say or or alternatively um we are going
to fuse and become ones with the
machines uh in which case it's just
going to be the the genesis of our
leveling up
yeah the singularity where we're all
living in the metaphors that's that's a
very bleak bleak note chris but i
i liked what you were saying about
um
the uh
i've lost my train of thought completely
i apologize that's fine fighting back
against it well what about you you
mentioned relationships there apart from
the technology element of this what did
you learn about men's
relationship with relationships
well when when i've
this all started
as i've said with conversations in pubs
that morphed into wider conversations
that became an article in my newspaper
entitled why are successful midlife men
unhappy that's quite a baiting
title in in the current environment and
i was thinking
this is going to this is going to end in
you know disaster but what actually
happened
is a
huge amount of men said that's
describing me
but interestingly a huge amount of their
partners said this is describing my
partner
and i think that you get you can get in
into a trap that it's it is a battle of
the sexes but the reality is most of us
live in
a relationship with someone from the
other
opposite sex and
it's
it's uh important that we we work
together rather than in opposition
so
for me
i found that doing a bit of work rather
than being this you know repressed guy
who's just i can't talk about anything
because if i do everything will fall
down
by doing a bit of work myself
i'm married to someone who has been
doing the work
for much longer than me because she's
much more open she's more emotionally
intelligent
all of the all of those cliches
but our relationship is is is
stronger now i've made the effort
and it is it is an effort you know
as you know from the book i haven't got
any master plan there's no easy
solutions to any of this and those books
where they promise that there is
are definitely lying but there are
little things that i've picked up along
the way and little
snippets of conversation like the
happiest guy i met in the whole in the
whole
research
the little things he said
just have made things better and that's
obviously if i'm happier my relationship
is better what were some of the
takeaways from that guy
have we got i'll tell you about the guy
so the guy was
um in his mid-twenties and he was doing
he's he was on his way doing all the
things that are expected of him got you
know done done school
left school
bottom of the career ladder and
set up a burglar alarm installation
business and it was going well he had a
house with a mortgage he was just
starting to pay off he had a serious
long-term girlfriend but the people who
have burglar alarms installed tend to be
older
so he was having coffee every day
with an oxygenarian who said
always how old are you he'd say 27 and
then they would spend the next five
minutes talking about all their regrets
and how much they wish they were 27
again
so this obviously got to him
finished with his girlfriend got rid of
the house binned the business and moved
to a caravan in next to loch ness in
scotland
[Music]
and he has lived there for the last 30
years and so
journalists have talked to him before
and he's always this sort of the
crackpot nessie hunter but we were
talking for and i was kind of in the
middle of all this fog of midlife and he
was describing i was saying come on you
know how can you possibly how can this
be a fun way to live and he just spoke
for about 10 minutes about
a weather front coming across the lock
and
light coming down
and it just shifted in a way that he'd
never seen before and he felt the
lightness inside him and i've tried a
lot of meditation over the years and
i've never quite got that kind of moment
of enlightenment that the real black
belt
uh monks talk about
but
i could i could feel i got what he was
saying
and
i just thought that's we can't all go
and live next to loch ness right that'd
be billions of caravans
wrecking lot ness
but
ever since that conversation i've
found that there are always moments in
the day regardless of how [ __ ] the day
is
where you can stop
and just appreciate it and this is this
is something the self-help gurus say all
the time live in the moment
live in the present
doesn't it doesn't work when you're
talking to a stressed out midlife man
it took that conversation with that guy
to realize there was some truth in it
doesn't have to be onerous or hard work
and that's what that's what's
been one of the changes that's helped me
what was some of the other
characteristics or traits that you found
that were common amongst the men that
seemed to have
it together or some part of it together
of the the reasons that they were
struggling no of the reasons that they
were doing well what were the
characteristics or traits that were
common amongst the men that were doing
well
well
the first one
the older men
the ones who were through it all
that that was something they they were
all i met a whole group of old guys and
it was really interesting talking to
them because
the traits they all had in midlife were
the same
that me and my midlife mates all had all
depressing
and they
now they were older and retired
they were they completely checked they
weren't thinking about the future
that was
not because they were about to drop dead
but because
you know they didn't have to worry about
things in the future other than
dying illness and death is quite
depressing i suppose but they were just
living in the present and i think
i think
the the younger people i i
spoke to the ones who
were
successful in life not in not in stuff
or careers
were the ones who somehow had managed to
stop giving so much of a [ __ ]
they just
didn't care and it's not that's not to
say they were kind of just slobbing
around not trying
they just weren't
what ifing about everything they weren't
like thinking three steps ahead
and being negative
they're just really
not quite case or asser are but because
they've you know they've still we've all
got pressures
but just if something bad happened well
that happened
and i would love to be better
at not caring so much you know not
always imagining the worst case scenario
and it i'd say i'm 10 better than i was
five years ago how much of that do you
think you can leapfrog
i read this in uh
johann hari's most recent book where he
said that
so many of the things that we ascribe to
our own personal development are simply
byproducts of us getting older
and as someone that spends a good bit of
time trying to expedite that process it
does
it fills me with a sense of kind of
futility that um all of the [ __ ] that i
might be doing and all of the progress
that i'm celebrating my wins for might
just be coming along for the ride as the
days go past but i wonder how much you
think we can we can expedite getting
from where you were to them or how much
of it's like like a conveyor belt that
you're just waiting for that moment to
arise
i yeah that's that is nonsense i think i
think
loads loads of
you can do you can do a lot i mean the
mere fact that you're talking about this
i wasn't even
thinking about all of this stuff when i
was your age and i've had a brilliant
conversations with people in their 20s
who
have read the book and and re you know
as i keep saying it's not a self-help
book but they've read what
what awaits them and thought
no i'm definitely not gonna i'm
definitely not gonna i'm gonna start
dealing with all this stuff now and it's
it's to do with talking it's to do with
opening up it's to do with pausing
and
i wish i'd started i really wish i'd
started earlier but then of course
that's me being regretful and negative
but i think there's there's amazing
opportunities
even in this more kind of stressed
and even more high-pressured
environment that young men are faced
with now
just by merely discussing it thinking
about it that's that's just
very positive about that
for you not for me
i think that the conversation's
progressing when i think about the guys
that i'm around and the sort of
conversations that we have i had a i got
a buddy out here who um
randomly out of nowhere got some travel
anxiety been on planes millions of times
before right it travels all over the
place and he really struggled to get on
a plane twice in a row
uh and he told me the story and he said
dude i felt like such a loser and i was
going back down the escalator or austin
airport uh having had my um girlfriend
come to collect me for now the fourth
time she dropped him off and collected
him
once then dropped him off and then had
to collect him again the second time
when he couldn't get himself onto this
plane and he was like dude i was i was
going down the conveyor belt and i felt
like such a loser and i had tears
streaming down my face and i just felt
like i was a complete waste of space and
like even in that moment for me i'm a
pretty open guy i was like wow like
that's such a a showing of
you know like you'd say that that's
brave and courageous to open up in that
sort of a way uh
and you know that that was a really
stark moment where i thought [ __ ]
hell like i wouldn't have i wouldn't
have spoken like that to my friends ten
years ago
he's having to admit to you that he's
not a manly man
in that specific instance
but
once you start having that level of
relationship it's really great i mean
i've
so many
friends are our relationships have
evolved because we're not just
taking the piss out of each other and
making light of everything you know we
it's not i mean the
the opposite end of that
is kind of those very serious men's
circles which i'm not saying are a bad
thing but they're not for everyone you
know where you're sitting in a circle
and you get 10 minutes to talk about how
awful everything is
there's there's a balance where it's
more organic
and
i think i i think
men aren't as
aren't as shamed by mentioning things
they're worried about as they used to be
definitely i mean definitely
if you look at
how it was in the 19th century just
crazy and it is
something that you've kind of referenced
that a couple of times now that sort of
victorian era whatever stoicism or idios
idiocy what what are some of the
examples that you're referring to there
total total stoicism i mean rudyard
kipling he was early 20th century he's
the guy that does the cakes right he's
the the man that does
apple bakewell tarts
before he was doing the bakewell tarts
he was
he he
forced i think i'm right in saying
his son who wasn't past fit to join the
first world war to he got him in anyway
and then of course he was killed you
know because it was far more important
that rudyard kipling's son was a manly
man
and
you not get killed i mean
milia the the repression around
sex
is was ridiculous
the repression of the the way kids were
educated was i mean obviously it's a
long time ago but what is interesting is
a lot of that stuff was still around in
the until the 60s really and then it was
a whole generation to move forward from
that for it to start filtering down into
the kids so we're alive at an
interesting time things are more
progressive
more positive
but the pressures are also always
ramping up as well and we're supposed to
remember we're supposed to have robots
doing all the work
by now and that obviously hasn't
happened
so it's a very
hated picture there's a concept called
conceptual inertia uh i spoke to a a
an ideas historian and his book was
about existential risk
but he identified that
a lot of the time even once something
let's say that you go from the
earth being the center of the universe
to the earth orbiting the sun right that
that movement from one type of
view of the
night sky to another one
let's say that first off it's not
accepted then it is accepted by society
at large and
downstream from the scientists but
people still don't act like it's
accepted for a while and this is this
conceptual inertia that it takes time
for things to sort of filter and bleed
through because culture moves
very very quickly on the surface but i
think that the subtexts and the
assumptions that people have they are
these big sort of lumbering behemoths
that get dragged along behind and it
takes a long long time i think back man
i think back to university and like
there wasn't even the ability to
satirically talk about someone being a
lad so in the uk that was
that was like the in-betweeners was one
of those moments where the super hyper
lads the jay from the in-betweeners
person was mockable like you would take
the piss out of that person because that
was someone that had taken masculinity
and just tuned it up to a million but
wasn't ever actually delivering on any
of this stuff and that was before that
was even a trope before he could even
there was there wasn't an archetype for
me to take the piss out of the guys from
being that way or for us to do it to
each other uh so when you think about
how quickly stuff on the surface has
changed yes but you go okay but there's
still all of these assumptions around
the way that men are supposed to be
about them taking their lay count as
like one of the fundamental sources of
value that they have it's how many girls
have slept with in the last year and
stuff like that
so yeah i
i think that the conceptual inertia
plays a big role in this
dispensed with what was victorian but
what did victorian cause and then what
was downstream from that and then how
long is it going to take to get rid of
it
yeah it's um
that's
that's such a great way of putting it
and
it's depressing in a way because things
do move slowly but i think i think we've
got a
it will be another couple of generations
but
so we need all these big societal
changes and they're happening they
really are but then it's the small
things that you do for yourself that are
that are
equally important and that's that's
things like having the conversations
for me taking a 20 minute break and
doing nothing every single day all the
really little practical things but in
order to get to that point
i had to i had to go through quite a lot
of
stop struggling stop trying to be a
manly man and just carrying on as if
everything's fine
and all of that nonsense and write a
whole book
and that as well yeah i think that that
the um going through the trenches and
the discomfort of arriving at those
realizations i think that that is quite
a big part of it and it's one of the
reasons why i would agree with you
you can expedite your progress towards
certain things but it's not simply a
fact of knowing whatever the strategy is
and then implementing it a lot of it is
the journey of discomfort along the
route to finding the strategy to falling
off to dropping the habit to re
rediscovering the habit to realizing
what life's like without it and so on
and so forth because
that is what gives you
it's what connects you to the reason
that you're doing a particular practice
because you realize what life is like
without doing that thing you realize
that having a 15 minute walk first thing
in the day makes my day better
oh wow i've just discovered this thing
and then over time you go through a
really bad day and you think well i'm
gonna go for this walk and you get back
and you go wow i feel better but without
the bad day you wouldn't have the
polarity that actually explains to you
why this is an important strategy it's
not just about arriving at some
perfectly optimized
life
routine where all of the problems have
gone away the problems that you work
through on route to achieving that
particular routine and having those
practices and having that world view i
think is the thing that makes the
difference and also you know people like
yourself that are breaking the fourth
wall around what it's like to be in a
like a kind of a weird period of of life
like what the what what is your 40s
really like what are they they're just
this
they're just this point at which you're
probably supposed to be a dad for a bit
and then you're maybe supposed to let
your kids go off to uni for a bit or
something or maybe not like what is it
yeah you're supposed to be a grown-up
and if and you're supposed to be
successful and you're supposed to have
it all together and it's i can assure
you i don't feel
different to when i was your age that's
the odd thing i don't feel
i mean i feel old one day and i feel
like i was 35 minutes ago
the next day so it's
it's it's tricky but you're right all of
this stuff it does take time and effort
and you know when i first started the to
use the well-being term forest bathing
which means just walking to the end of
the road
standing under a tree
um you know which we're always told
you've got to do that it's good to clear
the head
and
for years obviously i just thought i
don't need to do that i'm all right and
then i started doing it out of just
desperation to find some way of pausing
thoughts
and
i'd say it was about
three months i was sitting under the
tree
still worrying about the mortgage what
it did because i didn't have my phone or
an audio book to plug in
i was just
like having a special time to worry
about stuff a bit more and it took
months to get to the point where
yes
finally
i've i don't care anymore i've got the
whole i really think that's
i've really done a lot of waffling today
but the
not caring is is the thing that i
think's worked most not not worst case
scenario in everything
and i can now do that under a tree every
day
like some kind of
proper monk
the rest of the day is all the same as
it always was still worrying about
everything
but that that's
that special moment is is really good
and that's taken three four years to get
to in total
matt rudd ladies and gentlemen if people
want to keep up to date with what you're
doing or harass you online where should
they go
i think we've discussed how i feel about
technology um if people want to shout at
me they can do that on twitter
um but otherwise
just leave me alone deal with your own
problems
that's the right thing to say you see
nothing self-help guru
i have to i will i know we're signing
off when people have got in touch i've
had some amazing conversations and so
i'd love to chat thanks matt what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace